I first heard about Hillsdale on a talk radio
program and got interested in it as a teenager.
I already knew that it was going to be a great
place, but it exceeded my expectations in
so many ways.
I've got to say that my time at Hillsdale--those
four years were the best four years of my
life.
Just an incredible experience.
I went to Hillsdale and I was eager to get
out into the world and change change the world.
Dr. Arnn would freely note that I was eager
to make a name for myself and be famous.
He reiterated time and again that I need to
study.
I need to focus on becoming a student.
I became a serious student.
Humble enough to really admit that I don't
know everything, that I have a lot more to
learn.
I am a State Representative for the twenty-fifth
legislative district in Puyallup, Washington.
This is my sixth year in the State House of
Representatives.
It's been a great experience getting to know
the community, getting to know a variety of
issues.
I'm constantly learning new things.
One of the very, very important things that
I learned at Hillsdale was the importance
of listening.
That's critical for serving in a public office.
And we have to find ways to strengthen our
communities, to leverage the relationships
that are found within our communities.
That is going to take a lot of hard work by
a lot of smart people, much like those who
are coming out of Hillsdale, who are willing
to run for public office, willing to get involved
in their communities, willing to volunteer
and spend the time and go to the meetings
and do all the other things that take up a
great deal of time, but that are very much
worth it because people have gone before us
and done that in ways that have allowed us
to be here and free.
I want to be a good dad.
I want to do well for my family.
I want to do well for my community.
I was very honored when I was told that I
was getting this award.
And knowing the caliber of some of the others
who have gotten this award, I'm particularly
humbled by it.
I think, more than anything else, it is a
challenge to me to keep striving.
It is a reminder to me of the principles and
values that Hillsdale stands for, and that
I ought to stand for in my life.
Hillsdale is doing a unique thing in the country.
And to be associated with that is an incredible
honor and it is something that I hold very
dear.